hello everyone and welcome to a game a
lot of you have suggested already and
for very good reasons it's Magnus
Carlsen versus Neha Cyrene and I've
included their handles and just 24 in
case you want to go check out their
games it's magazine box of course most
of you know carson's but it's a Neha
serine all lowercase for goodness heaven
here and it's from crossings banter
blade session that took place yesterday
and it's well it's quite the game and
quite the opening that was used so
without further ado I'm sure you all
know what what I'm talking about
let's check it out so Magnus opens with
E 4 we have E 5 Knight to f3 Knight to
c6 Bishop to c4 calls and goes for the
Italian game Bishop to c5 the Joko piano
and now we have it be for the Evans
gambit and yes in this position it was
in fact played so really really really
excellent stuff maybe maybe today it
will not be used in a in a classical
game or maybe even in a rapid game
although some grandmaster still used it
in rapid for for a 3-minute blitz game
it's it's more than enough
so before asking me how do you want to
accept the gambit so he does Bishop
captures and before and the Evans is one
of those games
gambit that is best refuted if accepted
Sox e3 now preparing to grab space in
the center and basically asking where do
you want to go with the Bishop Bishop
here here here or maybe here maybe even
here
c5 not a c5 is not all the great
basically it's a choice between a 5 and
e7 but in in modern days in the era of
engines even Bishop to d6 became an
option but ok Bishop to a5 going for the
older continuation but we have d4 by
Magnus and d6 now not going for any pawn
grabbing in maybe maybe in Morpheus time
we would definitely see character as
Queen b3 then after this is defended
maybe black would even capture on c3 and
so on some very very famous out of
understand games in those lines but ok
setting defends with b6 we have Queen to
b3 now putting pressure on f7 in the
Queen to d7 now the
much better than Queen to e7 as Queen to
e7 allows d5 for white and then you you
don't really have any squares for the
Knights to go if you kick it away with
d5 the knight has nowhere to go you'd
have to go either either here which is
bad or maybe to b8 which is a starting
square so leaving the option if y
decides to go d5 but D captures on e5 by
Magnus and now while recapturing is
perfectly fine for black Bishop to b6 is
the strongest move for black here neo
shows that he knows is some theory
behind the Evans gambit so he captures
an b6 magnus grabs another phone the
point is you want a free the a5 square
for the Knights to get a double attack
on the Queen and the bishop and to
eliminate White's light square Bishop
which is extremely strong so each
character sin b6 and now Knight to a5
with Queen to b5 offering a queen trade
Knight captures on c5 and Magnus has to
recapture Queen characters in the now C
characters and v6 Queen there doesn't
seem to be anything wrong with Queen
just Queen captures on d6 that seems
like a reasonable thing to do you keep
your pawns intact
but if for a three-minute blitz game you
kind of don't want to meet anymore you
don't know how to handle so C captures
although it creates an isolated pawn is
a safer option
now you're just ready to go develop the
knight castle you don't have to worry
about he 5 and so on so here Magnus
castled and here we have Knight to e7
there is a game from 1964 simultaneous
exhibition in New Orleans where Knight
to f6 was played where the player with
the white pieces with Bobby Fischer he
was holding the simultaneous exhibition
and Fischer actually actually lost that
game to Parham after it was it was a
very nice game we we still haven't
covered it but we will at some point so
that's a possibility Knight f6 but nice
the e7 is a new move by setting and it
is as a remove 12 that we have a
completely new game so Magnus continues
in the style of the Evans gambit Bishop
to a3 you of course always want your
dark square Bishop on this diagonal well
most of the times we have castles and
now rook to d1 piling up on the d6 pawn
but Annie Hall decided long ago
this is a three minute blitz game we're
not going to be counting pawns Queen to
g4 he goes for the attack he wants to
bring the knight here and and start an
attack against the white king with the
bishops pointing in the right direction
of course
so Magnus grabs it Bishop captures on d6
and the bishop can now retreat the g3 it
will be a valuable defensive piece we
worship the e6 grabbing more development
in preparing to bring the rook into the
game Queen back to e to buy Magnus and
now Knight to g6 so now the knight can
can either come to maybe maybe to a4 in
the future or maybe even to h4 we have
h3 by Magnus keeping the Queen away
Queen to h5 and now Knight B to d2 a
preparing Knight to F 1 followed by
Knight to g3 to further pick away the
Queen now we have looked after DN by
serine and now Knight the f1 preparing
Knight to g3 like we mentioned and here
like I said the bishop will be a
valuable defensive piece if if it goes
back so here a certain goal decides to
go go all out but the rook captures the
bishop on d6 we have rook captures and
now the f4 squadron is no longer guarded
by the bishop so Knights the f4 comes
with an attack on the Queen and here you
have to be very careful the Queen has to
go to d1 it's the only good Square for
the Queen and this is what Carlsen does
because you have to keep an eye on the
night otherwise if you move the Queen
away from the defense of the night you
allow Bishop captures then you remove
the defender of the night then Queen
captures Knight and so on so Magnus goes
for the absolute best move Queen D 1 and
now Bishop captures on h3 is having
steel still goes for it now feel free to
pause the video and decide whether it's
okay to capture the bishop while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting that no it is
most certainly not okay to capture the
bishop and for those of you who just
won't enjoy show here Magnus just
continued Knight the g3 and it is in
fact the best move point is that if the
bishop is captured you run in tonight
captures with check King has to move
otherwise if you go to the H file in
front of the Queen then just night-night
delivers the discovery pics of the Queen
kingi - is basically your only move but
now night captures an F - and now you
don't really have a move because you're
either losing the Queen or if you move
the Queen let's say Queenie - doesn't
really matter just queen ish - Richart
fall by things you want and Quinta h1
will be made so after Bishop captures on
h3 cross and goes night the g3 first we
have Queen - g4 now again with a very
nice threat of just Queen captures in g3
because the bishop pins DF pawn so
that's the threat and now Magnus decides
it's time to give back some material to
take control of this game
rook captures on b6 that's that's the
stuff now there is no more threat of
Queen captures here and you have to you
have to decide what are you gonna do
here so basically if you if you capture
the rock punk pawn captures you're just
gonna face characters captures and now
yes you are threatening mate but they're
there there's Queen to f1 you can defend
defend mate like this there's also
nicely one even better just nicely
defending that you don't have to
overcome it with your queen today - keep
on defending and here white will just be
up a piece and it doesn't seem very
likely that black can somehow get get a
get more out of this attack so nickel
instead of recapturing the sides we said
we're going all out so we are going all
out Bishop captures and G - now with the
threat of Bishop captures an f3 while
still having the option of recapturing
the rook and now what do you do here
again it's not not an easy decision for
example if you try something like nice -
H - to force a queen trade Anejo would
happily trade Queens because after
captures captures and characters here
the material is equal will be pieces
wise but nickel is also up a pawn it's a
double beep on but still it's a better
position for black so Crossin and does
not have the option of doing anything
like this there is one move that is that
is just excellent for white so once
again feel free to pause the video and
try to find this move that is absolutely
best for Magnus while I give you a
couple of seconds so for those who were
able to do it congratulations unsporting
blacks back rank issues and for those of
you just wanna enjoy - oh it's erupted
b6 defend and a
now black no longer has time to capture
on f3 because of rook to d8 check which
will be followed by captures and Queen
delivers mate so an eagle has to do
something about this
he could go h5 which seems like like a
good choice maybe he will have the
option of going h4 in the future but he
decides for rook to f8 instead which
doesn't really solve any of his problems
Magnus just goes rook to d8 and now he
wants the trade again saying you still
don't have time for captures here
because if you capture now it's a pretty
much the same eight captures captures in
Queen to d8 would mate so Nihal tried
the g6 here but now it's far too late
rook captures an f-18 captures and now
Queen the d6 with track we have King to
g8 and now comes the night the h2 now
finally getting the knight out of harm's
way with an attack on the Queen Queen to
h4 and now calm wrote the d1 threatening
Queen to d8 which will come with check
and the Queen's are coming off the board
so there's really not much to do here
and well again you don't have much time
to think it's a three-man blitz game so
Bishop to h3 was played at getting the
bishop out of harm's way as the knight
is pretty much stuck there defending it
so Queen to d8 by Magnus and this comes
with the church you have to trade
captures captures with the check and
came to g7 and it's already in this
position that you might resign but it's
a dream in the Blitz game so now of
course an eagle sorry I see is an
extremely fast player he made a few more
moves
rook to e8 cross and played it with a6
defending rook to b8 and now b5 and rook
to be six now going after the a6 pawn
Bishop to e6 up recurring thief Bishop
to c4 to try and hold at least a little
bit maybe he can win Magnus and against
Magnus on time with a3 defending the
pawn and now h5 and now cross and we'll
have to prove his technique being a rock
up we have Knight to f3 Knight to the h3
with check King g2 Knight f4 check King
to h2 now there are no more checks here
nice the d3 going after the pond but
Carson says you you have your pawn rook
to a7
we have night captures on f2 now tonight
the d4 we ignite the g4 with check King
to g2 now Knights the e5 adding more
defenders here to the f7 pawn and now
Knight G to e 2 by Magnus just nicely
really maneuvering we have Knights 2 D 3
and now King to f3 so here they were
extremely low on time so now most of the
moves aren't all that impressive Knights
that you want check King to e3 and all
night the C to check in such severe time
pressure and e2 blunders a piece here
Knight captures on e2 and now starts
pushing his pawn Knight C to D for by
Magnus with King to h6 we have Knight to
f4 g5 attacking the knight Knight to h3
we have King to h5 and now Knights theft
is still not resigning h3 we have rook
to e8 now getting the King is it the
room behind the King King gauge for and
now rook the h8 with check we have King
to g3 and now rook captures on h3 with
check with King to g2 and here you you
could deliver a very Swift to mate with
Knight to f3 there's not much you can do
here if let's say Bishop to e6 you're
just gonna go 91 check King has to go
back on location will be made but with a
little time on the clock cousin went for
a different idea rook to f3 instead now
we have G for group 2 F 4 and now King
to G 1 and here Magnus just captured the
G for pawn sorry
after King to g1 Magna just captured the
G for pawn and it was in this position
unmoved 56 that me how serene resigned
the game well rather he lost on time he
didn't resign the game so he of course
you are completely lost after King F 1
you are just getting made there's
nothing you can do here but all in all
other than all those moves that were
made as it is as it is a game on time
the first and the first some 25 moves
after this
23rd move rook to d6 by Magnus really
really impressive stuff and basically
the game was concluded in some 25 moves
which is to be expected when there when
the Evans gambit is on the board and
either Serena would have preferred
with his attack on the king said he
didn't want to play against the Evans
gambit directly he didn't want to accept
material and then be under attack he
instead gave up that d6 pawn started an
attack of his own and India and it just
didn't work out but this is the kind of
game you get when one of the players
actually goes for the Evans gambit and
here we we had the privilege of seeing
it played on the highest level by none
other than world champion Magnus Carlsen
so that's the game I do hope you enjoyed
it a lot of other very interesting
openings occurred during the band for
blitz so I might show one more game
we'll see if you guys enjoyed this one
but yeah really really impressive stuff
whenever you see the Joker piano on the
board do go for the Evans gambit you
will have an awesome time maybe not if
it's an important classical game but in
an online blitz game I definitely go for
it so like I said I do hope you enjoyed
it I would like to thank matthias jakob
dario Jovanka which in the repair eo1
wolf and alexander a fancy F for
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot - really appreciate it as usual you
can check - on my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
Morphy saga checking up on your one of
the suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world so thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day